So welcome everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We are going to be talking about just some questions that everybody has
That I've had given to talk about so
First thing is first
I have
The pictures of marijuana in the macro because we're gonna talk about marijuana
So I had to pull a picture for my slide. So we're gonna talk about marijuana and the use of marijuana first
So
There's a lot of information on the internet about the use of marijuana for cancer and live
Incredict paid and autoimmune diseases and
We have to be careful with information that's out there. So first of all my wardied number one is that
there is no
Hands down to cure for anything
And marijuana is another one of those things that could be very helpful, but it's not a hands down cure for anything
so
Just let's make that perfectly clear
Prodo cell has cured a lot of people mushrooms have kids cured a lot of people
S.E.I.C. has cured a lot of people when I say cure
I'm talking about that person's definition of cure because honestly if you've heard anything that I've said
Over the last 20 years, you know that I don't believe that we're cured except by God doing a curing in us
So I don't believe that there's any natural quote-unquote cures. I believe that we are managing our state
Then we live in a fallen world and we're gonna manage our state to this fallen world until we're taken away
Now I don't want to die of cancer and you don't want to die of cancer or
Lyme disease or anything else. So we do our best to manage our state
So we can be in a state of remission and be healthy and
As fulfilled as we possibly can during that state. Now the use of marijuana
Or cannabis is just another herb that may possibly help people
So there's three different
Uses of marijuana. So in this picture we have a CBD oil in this spot right here
We have smoky marijuana and we have rick Simpson's oil
So this is the three different uses of marijuana. So smoky marijuana. What would that help anybody?
So I am not in favor of recreational use of marijuana because it could
A long-term recreational use of marijuana could have an effect on a person's brain and
That's not what we want. So it could
Decrease different neuronal centers and it could decrease
The function of different neurotransmitters and that could be beneficial. We're talking about that a second
But long-term recreational use of marijuana is not what we're talking about
Medicinal use of marijuana is what we want to discuss. So why would a person smoke marijuana or
Use it in a heated state like cooking it in a brownie or a cookie or something like that
What would be the benefit is that use of marijuana that spike of a mild THC get a kill cancer cells and my opinion no
It's not going to kill cancer cells
But the benefit of smoky marijuana is that it could take away pain
It can increase appetite
It can induce sleep
It can
Just give take away anxiety
So those are all huge benefits if I'm dealing with anxiety pain
Inability to get rest don't have any appetite
So smoking marijuana can be extremely beneficial using opioids to deal with my pain as addictive and it's dangerous
And it has a whole bunch of side effects and it constipates you and all sorts of blah blah blah blah
Bare one doesn't have any of those side effects
So I would much rather see a person smoking marijuana
Than using opioids and the reason why it's still illegal in most states is
Because the pharmaceutical companies haven't figured out how to make money on it yet
That's very unfortunate. It isn't herb and I know that a lot of people are against it personally
I have never smoked marijuana. I've never smoked cigarette
So I would not use it unless I was in a state that I needed to use it for those above reasons
But so I can't give you any first-hand, you know
Benefits of marijuana benefit to be quite honest. You can see I just pulled this picture off the web right there
And I just I don't even know if that's correct, okay?
So I don't have any first-hand experience with the use of marijuana
So but a lot of my patients have said that it has
Replaced payments or it could diminish the amount of
Payments that they need and that's that's a big plus and if it could increase appetite
It increased sleep then it's a big plus so smoking marijuana could be very beneficial
And I know a lot of people like have a really hard time with that because they're law-abiding citizens and that's a wonderful attribute
She got to remember it's simply an herb that grows in the
In the meadows and God created it. So why it's illegal. It's that's another question to answer
So another use of the
cannabis plant is CBD oil. So there's two major components of
cannabis CBD and THC
So the CBD oil you'll read a lot of stuff about CBD oil and cancer that it could kill cancer and such
There's not a whole lot of research evidence that suggests that that's true though
So when we talk about we want to take a
Marijuana for killing cancer. We're really talking about the high THC oil
So the high THC oil or what was called rick Simpson's oil
It actually rick Simpson's oil is much more viscous than this. This is actually not a very good picture
But it usually comes in a syringe. It ricks Simpson's oil is dosed
Typically when you syringe out the size of a grade of rice
So you take start with one grade a day
You move to one grade three times a day that ultimately the dose is three grades of rice three times a day is the full dose
And rick Simpson used to dose people rick Simpson is a native name of a guy who kind of developed this and he used to make it and give it away for free to cancer patients
He was thrown in jail several times
But now he can't get it from him, but it's been nicknamed rick Simpson's oil
So rso oil or rick Simpson oil is the strong
blood
distilled down version of THC. So it's a very high THC concentration
Now I'll tell you most of my patients that go on rick Simpson's oil do not like the side effects
So that's the negative of rick Simpson oil. It has a lot of side effects and we can make you feel really groggy
Could just make you not feel good could just kind of just don't feel well
So there is another way there's multiple different ways to take rick Simpson oil. Although the way he used to dose it is just what I said
Take three grades of rice three times a day morning nude and evening
Now you can get up to full dosage by simply
put it in a suppository
capsule and
Using it as a suppository before you go to bed or even a better way is to take those grades of rice
Put it in a make make your old capsule out of coconut oil
Put the grades of rice in there
Folded into coconut oil and freeze them and make your own suppositories with coconut oil
In the rick Simpson oil in the suppositories and just take that before you go to bed
So that can reduce the symptoms
Though I've had I've had patients go I'm not really helped a lot and I could take it
No problem. I could get up to full dose take it as a suppository before I go to bed
And I don't have so many symptoms
Most of the people that I've talked to them done that still say they have some symptoms
But it's a whole lot better than doing chemo and if it's working, that's what we care
Now the only way you're going to know that it's working or not is to try it
And rick Simpson oil is legal in many states. It's not legal in my state
We don't have any of these things to test the person on so I can't test the person because I'm not going to jail to have an illegal substance
in my clinic
So I could teach you about it. There's nothing wrong with that, but you're going to have to get that from another source
The CBD oil why would you want to use that? Well CBD oil can help with pain
One of the great things that CBD oil could do is decrease anxiety
I think it decreases glutamate levels and it decreases inflammation of the brain
So CBD oil has been touted big time
Use with the people that have
Seasures it's been extremely helpful for people that have seizures
So CBD oil
rick Simpson's oil so CBD
The rick Simpson oil is the high THC and smoking marijuana the three uses of marijuana
Smoketer use it in some sort of edible if you use an edible
I know in a lot of the legal states you could get gummy bears and
Edibles in a sweet source
We don't recommend that because you want it in a fat
This
THC is a fat-cellulable substance so if you can keep it in a fat, you're going to keep it in the body longer
So if someone gifted you some gummy bears
And you would you don't want a spike high that's not what we're shooting for right
We want this log standing in our system so it decreases pain
You could take the gummy bear and stick it in a tablespoon of coconut oil and swallow it down
That way and that will help as your body absorbs the fat with the marijuana
Then you will have a more slower
Not such a spike a slower upward curve
It'll stay in your body a little bit longer so that could have some greater benefits
But that's the use of marijuana and you want more information about that make sure you just schedule a time to talk to us
Um, I know with a state of Minnesota if you are a diagnosed with kids or you could get a marijuana
cannabis card
So in a lot of states you could apply for a cannabis card. They're giving it to you in a little bit different form though
Um, it's a pharmaceutical form. It's in a capsule
I'm not quite sure if uh
Then it works quite as well to be honest with you
But if you could get it your jurisprudence for that's just great
I've been told by a number of people that they could get a cannabis card
And then they could get it from the state, but then the insurance doesn't pay for that. So
Uh, it's kind of a catch-22. They legalize it
They as long as the pharmaceutical company can sell it make money off of it
And it sure as companies will pay for well, that's just
sticks
so um
I know that um, you could
Fight it in a lot of different states and where it's legal and utilize it that way
The second thing I wanted to talk to you about today, which I don't have a slide on is um
questions that people had about the rife and
Feeling the effects of the rife when you start and you are
Dealing with kids are and dealing with line
So let's talk about that because that's two different
Things that we're dealing with
Depending on what we're trying to kill
So remember go back to some of the videos on the rife technology and what it does
Some of our earlier zoom calls in August or September we had
Video on the rife and went into more detail about that
So I challenge you to go back and look those up and and um watch those
Uh, but uh, I just want to touch on it here
So what we're trying to do with the rife machine is to program frequencies
That will affect cancer cells or live
Co-infections and birelia bacteria and other bacterial and viral co-infections
So with cancer let's talk about that first
What happens if I'm running the rife and I don't feel good
What I'm running the rife?
Is that a good side or a bad side what I'm trying to kill cancer
By opinion that's an extremely good sign
So we want the rife frequencies to be killing cancer cells. That's what our desire is
If it is effectively doing that
We could feel a little queasy we could feel a little
Just icky we could feel a little nauseous
That's what we want it to be doing
Now not always because at the rate that of the death of the cancer cell you might not feel anything
And most patients don't feel anything so don't flip this around and say
Well, I've been running it and I don't feel anything so it must not be working for me. That's not true
But if you do feel that way if you feel nauseous you feel sick and you have pain it hurts
Right and by liver what I'm doing the rife that's actually a very good sign however
It's not always pleasant to feel that way
So you may want to slow things down a little bit
By moving the ball a little bit away from you
Because then you're not going to have the same effect on the
The cancer cell it's not going to kill it as fast and
It's it's going to slow things down and you won't have the you know the same death rate and the cancer cells
And but you won't feel so bad
So you might want to put the ball a little bit away from you and
And slow down a little bit or you might want to suck it up and
struggle through it because you're going to kill it a faster rate
So that's my opinion about the rife and cancer
It's completely different by opinion is when we talk about Lyme disease
Because when we're killing a bacteria
That is a gram-negative bacteria like beryllia, burgodorfii, Lyme disease and all of its co-infections
Gram-negative bacteria by their very nature
Have a lipopolysaccharide in the
in the cell membrane
So when you kill that bacteria you
liberate the lipopolysaccharides
The lipopolysaccharides are large enough molecules that will stimulate an immune response
Well, most Lyme patients, most Lyme patients are phase three Lyme or stage three Lyme
That means they're at an autoimmune phase
And if you're at an autoimmune phase, you have antibodies to your own cells
That's the definition of autoimmune disease
So if I am antibodies to my own neurons
And I kill back the bacteria too quickly
And I liberate too much lipopolysaccharides
I will stimulate an immune response
And when I ever stimulate an immune response
I will kill that which I have antibodies against first
Namely my neurons
So if my Lyme patients say I didn't feel good after I rife last night
I say you need to move the bulb farther away from you
Because we don't want to be stimulated in a immune response
And killing your neurons hits you not feeling well
So with my Lyme patients, I don't want them to feel worse after rifeing
That means we're killing the bacteria too quickly
And we're stimulating in a immune response
And then we're killing self-tissue
So two opposite answers
I don't feel well after I rife last night
Do you have cancer?
Yes
Well then keep doing it
Answer number two
I don't feel well after I rife last night
Do you have Lyme?
Yes
Well then you need to move the bulb farther away from you tonight
Now also understand each one of your nights are different
So in a cancer patient you might not be running the exact same frequencies tomorrow
So you might not feel that way at all
I know that that could happen quite frequently
So a person is running the rife
And it's only between one and one 30 that they felt this way
And woke them up and they didn't feel good
And they had to get up and take a Tylenol or something
Well usually if you just get up and walk around
That's going to go away
And you can go back and lay down
And the rife is running on a different frequency
That might have affected you the same way
So we remember it cycling through a couple hundred frequencies every night
And it was just some specific frequency that night
That was really hitting you hard
So if you're a cancer patient
You kind of want to take note of that
And tell me about it that
Boy at Wednesday night at one o'clock
I tell you it was just knocking my socks off
Well that's a good thing
We may want to run Wednesday night
More frequently during the week
Not just on Wednesday night
Because we want to knock the socks off that cancer
So you understand my philosophy there
So it's a good thing for a cancer patient
To feel a little icky after the rife
Okay so hopefully that answers some of your questions
I'm going to open up the mic for everybody
And let you ask other questions if you have questions
So your mics are open
Any other questions anybody have
Dr. Connors can you hear me
I can hear you perfect
Okay
Well this is crystal and I'm in a combine shell and corn
So I'm
You wait a second
You are in a combine
I'm shell and corn
Okay this is a first
Yeah it's organic too
Oh my goodness
So anyway
I'm struggling with insomnia
I can fall asleep but I can't stay asleep
And um it's
Other video
Okay let's talk about that
So if a person can fall asleep
But then they can't stay asleep and they wake up
Do you wake up and then you can't fall back asleep again?
No I can fall back asleep again
So do you wake up like 20 times or
Of five or six
Okay so you're waking up but you just fall asleep right away
But then you wake up again and you're falling asleep or where
Okay so you're not getting into a stage 4 sleep
So there's a difference between
So what if you can't fall asleep
That's problem number one totally different than a person who can fall asleep
Wakes up but then can fall asleep again
And then problem number three is a person who can fall asleep wakes up and then can't fall asleep
Three completely different types of insomnia
So your type is the second type you can fall asleep wake up and fall asleep again
You're not getting into a stage 4 sleep
So there's all sorts of different possibilities
They're not allowing you to get into a stage 4 sleep
The first most common thing is anxiety
So if my glutamate levels in my brain are ramped up
I can fall asleep because I'm tired
But then I won't get into a deep sleep
So multiple things can ramp up our glutamate levels
Consummate glutamates
Consummate glutamate that converts to glutamate
glutamate is the glutamate acid found in protein
Stress
Will ramp up my glutamates
And um
The um
Your brain waves
So you have four major brain waves in your brain
The highest frequency brain wave is called a beta wave
And the beta wave functions about 25 to 28
The high beta wave goes up to 32 hertz
Now it's important to know that
Because you can stimulate your brain at a beta wave
Or above
And it's hard to get your brain waves down to a sleep mode
Which is to get in a stage 4 sleep
You have to be at about 4 to 7 hertz
So think of a frequency of 4 to 7 cycles per second
Compared to a frequency of 30 cycles per second
So your brain is revved up
So this is just another possible cause of this, all right
One of the things that could rev up your brain
Is
Screen time
So the city here
City here talking to you
I'm looking at my computer screen
Which is
Every screen computer screen tv screen
Your phone screen
Is vibrated at a frequency of 60 hertz
That's how those are being
So we are basically in what's called
Intrating our brain at 60 hertz
When we're looking at a television before we go to bed
So this might not be you
Because you're sitting at a combine
Shocking cord right now
So
But the average person is watching a lot of tv
And sitting in front of their computer a lot during the day
So they are stimulated at their brain at 60 hertz
For many hours
And wonder they can't get into a stage 4 sleep at night
So that's another possibility
There's a few other possibilities that we could talk about
In person you just you and I
But when I said glutamate levels due to consumption of glutamate, glutamate
Stress
And brain waves could affect that second type of insomnia
Okay, thank you
That help
Yes
So that's what we tell with kids that aren't getting good night's sleep
And they can't
You know they are waking up all the time
We tell parents to limit your kid's screen time
But what are their ADD-HD about stuff the wall
You're
Intrating their brain at 60 hertz
Especially when their brain is growing
And you can't figure out why you can't get them to calm down and listen to things
Well to calm down and listen to things you have to be at about 10-12 hertz
And no wonder they can't get down to 10-12 hertz
Their brain is running at an ultra-super high beta wave that doesn't even
Supposed to be at a height
So
Screen time is limited is important
Okay, thank you very much
Any other questions
So we have a chat question
I'm going to un-share by screen here, okay
But you can still hear me yes
Yeah
Okay, so you can't see my screen anymore correct everybody
Correct
Okay, good
So we have a patient that asked a question about
Right, so we're going to talk to them individually any other questions
Yes, no
Okay, so we're at about our 30 minutes here
Remember also I'm going to remind you again if you have other questions
That you want to stay anonymous with you can email the questions to the clinic email
And then what are the staff grabs those and writes them down or sends them to me so that I address them on the next zoom call
So
Make sure you do that we want all your questions answered we don't want anybody bad because we didn't get their questions answered
But I can answer the question if you don't ask it so make sure you do that
All right, thank you everybody for attending this will be recorded this is recorded and I will
Upload it to YouTube and get it on Facebook
For everybody and thank you for attending
Thank you bye-bye